[Music]
when i watch your show i get real tense
yeah you have to watch it the next
morning yeah watch in the morning yeah
what were you going to say that
something goes up inside back inside you
those are my back my butts your butt
cheeks yeah
i just call them my butts yeah
yeah because you don't want to poop do
zombies yeah they must because they eat
they eat humans
i will be honest with you i've never
thought of a zombie being like
one minute
you're yeah religious right uh i am i've
actually tried a little bit of
everything little dab a little dab yeah
i was raised christian
and then regular regular regular i mean
like half record regular um
no regular my well a little bit my my
grandmother was catholic
and then you know so a little decaf a
little regular yeah
little unleaded little premium yeah
exactly i'll let you choose which one's
premium 89 baby
um is that an octane joke yeah
looking at your headshot i wouldn't be
like she's going to be making a lot of
automobile humor
yeah you look more like pillows milk
bounds
i feel like you could make your own
better yeah my own butter yeah i like
turning in i
i'm not making a jerk joke i just mean
like you make
yeah apparently it's quite easy to make
butter yeah cheers
oh no no no it was great it was great i
uh you know i'm missing one of the
single men that you hear about no you're
not yeah i'm a single man ah
but you're so funny oh that's our time
i think we've accomplished what we
wanted to accomplish here thank you very
kindly
that is like that's like a rainy day
i'll just remember that you said that
yeah we'll end with this i understand
you have a dog
i do have a dog what's your dog's well
i'll guess your dog's name okay
scrappy no samuel no james brown
no that's great that's a good brownie if
he's brown
right now he's a little rocker the
hardest working dog in children yeah
just tell me your dog's aiming for alvin
alvin yeah does he have a shirt with a
nail
in hindsight no he doesn't but he does
uh he hangs out at the office the
production office when we're shooting
yeah
and i came back one time and he'd been
dressed up like tom cruise from risky
business
with ray-bans i don't agree with with
dressing up dogs
on the bus he's a big dog though he's
like you know 40 pounds
it's such a terrible thing to do to a
dog but it's the best it is
what a horrible thing to impose upon it
i love it so much
thank you so much for coming yeah of
course thank you i'm gonna hug you
i would do better but it's just such a
little dress i know
[Music]